[Musik]
und man hat vielleicht die hoffnung dass
es damit dann jetzt noch schneller in
die cafés oder biergärten gehen kann
denn jetzt ein bier mit freunden das wär
was vor allem jetzt wo über ganz
deutschland die sonne wieder scheint
aber stattdessen muss in deutschland
jetzt bier weggeschüttet werden ja das
haben sie jetzt richtig gehört warum
genau das weiß mein kollege phil hacke
man ja wir stehen hier in der ailinger
brauerei bei münchen wo ein für
bierliebhaber wahrscheinlich
herzzerreißendes ereignis stattfindet
und zwar muss hier inzwischen literweise
bier vernichtet werden was wegen dem
locker und nicht verkauft werden konnte
hier werden pro woche knapp 10.000 liter
bier jetzt vernichtet das entspricht
einem wirtschaftlichen verlust von
20.000 euro und das ist wirklich schlimm
und darüber möchten wir jetzt sprechen
mit dem brauereidirektor der eigener
brauerei hartmann
was macht das mit ihnen wenn sie diese
bilder hier sehen wie sie sagen jetzt
zerreisst und ich als brauer auch
braumeister weiß was für eine arbeit
hinter dem produkt steht von der
landwirtschaft ersten am bau angefangen
bis hin zu wochenlanger arbeit und sowas
vernichtet man dann innerhalb von
wenigen sekunden nur aufgrund ja sogar
mal so nicht politisch sag mal so
konzeptioniert richtige entscheidungen
was ist denn der hintergrund dieser
vernichtung warum sind die notwendig
geworden also man muss einfach
zurückgehen
natürlich leidet die gastronomie als
partner die die brauereien als partner
gaz mich seit märz letzten jahres im
september letzten jahres war es halt so
dass wir uns entscheiden mussten was
füllen wir in fässer in flaschen ab
politik sagte damals noch
weihnachtsgeschäft oder weihnachten wird
geöffnet im januar können wir auch
wieder öffnen im vertrauen auf diese
aussagen haben wir im september oktober
noch bier gefüllt aber leider durften
wir jetzt das seit september oktober
auch nicht mehr verkaufen
und da das mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum für
bier im fass ungefähr bei sechs monaten
liegt sind wird seit ende februar seit
jetzt märz eigentlich in der lage dieses
wunderbare produkt zu vernichten was hat
das denn auch für wirtschaftliche folgen
für sie jetzt und was würden sie sich
diesbezüglich von der politik erhoffen
ja eigentlich es gibt vielerlei
möglichkeiten natürlich wer mal das
thema perspektiven aufzuzeigen dass die
gastronomie feste veranstaltungen dass
wir hier irgendwo mal wieder 1 1 ein
licht am tunnel am ende des tunnels
sehen das wirklich zu sagen ihr habt im
april die möglichkeiten der bier zu
verkaufen
schnelle hilfe wäre zum beispiel auch
dieses bier dass man hier leider gerade
vernichten müssen auch irgendwo ein
ersatz dafür bekommen wir haben es einst
unverschuldet letztendlich nicht
verkaufen können
es gibt größere maßnahmen wo ich sage
thema biersteuer wo der bund wo das land
aktiv werden kann wie er es nennt das
stichwort biersteuer mengen staffel wird
jetzt den rahmen sprengen
aber hier müssten wir wieder die
situation die 2003 in der bundesrepublik
herstellen also das sind themen wo auch
die brauereien die wirklich stark leiden
derzeit geholfen werden kann
und letzte frage wie sehen ihre
aussichten aus wie blicken sie in die
zukunft glauben sie dass es jetzt besser
wird und produzieren sie dann jetzt auch
entsprechend wieder
ja sie hat das ganze paradox an der
ganzen situation hier vernichten wir auf
der einen seite bier auf der anderen
seite müssen wir haben uns entschlossen
die produktion wieder hochzufahren
in der hoffnung dass wir ende märz
anfang april wie der unsere gastronomie
partner feste veranstaltungen beliefern
können und somit müssen wir reagieren
wir bauen die vorlaufzeit von sechs bis
zehn wochen und deswegen müssen wir
jetzt schon reagieren obwohl wir nicht
sicher wissen wie lang ein loch da noch
das ja das zeigt in der realität
natürlich auch wie die wirtschaft nach
vorne planen muss
wir hoffen auf jeden fall dass hier
nicht noch viel mehr bier in den gully
gekippt werden muss und damit zurück zu
dir nele
vielen dank für das hoffen wir auf jeden
fall auch und dass das jetzt neu
gebraute bier dann ganz schnell in
möglichst im biergarten wieder getrunken
werden kann vielen dank an dich mehr
nachrichten und bikinis nur bei bild
die ich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren